I wager that a good number of artists
and ambitious creative people like
myself spend a dreadful amount of time
considering their legacy how will I be
remember what works of mine if any will
carry on into posterity immortality
through art to give you a sense of time
if Shakespeare wrote Romeo and Juliet
today
critics and all lovers of the written
word would still be poring over its
possible meanings in the year 24 31 ad
if Plato uploaded the Republic onto the
Kindle library this afternoon political
scholars would still be debating its
efficacy in 4408 or as it's popularly
known you're 92 after the pan galactic
battle of gemini centauri long live the
republic the yearning for such
immortality is no doubt a stupid
Enterprise born of some combination of
narcissism insecurities and the fear of
death and it doesn't even solve the real
problem as Woody Allen said I don't want
to achieve immortality through my work I
want to achieve immortality through not
dying
of course the appealing thing about
having your work live on is that
presumably it's the best part and
history can graciously forget the rest
I want my as yet unwritten Great
American Novel to achieve posthumous
acclaim not this picture of me and the
raccoon that was apparently living on my
head some things we want to be forgotten
well that's easier said than done in the
Internet age in 1998 the Spanish
newspaper La Vanguardia published a
local announcement about the forced sale
of a home due to outstanding social
security debts the property and the
debts belonged to a Spanish lawyer named
mario costeja gonzalez in 2009 eleven
years later Gonzalez didn't appreciate
that
even then when you searched his name on
Google what you saw at the top of the
results was this small financial lapse
from the late 90s didn't he have a right
for that information to be lost
Gonzalez contacted La Vanguardia and
asked for them to take the story down
they said no so he filed a complaint
with the Spanish Data Protection Agency
asking for the paper to remove the story
and also for Google
to do the same from its search engines
the agency director rejected the request
to the newspaper but upheld the one to
Google telling them to remove the links
and make access to that data impossibly
after some wrangling and appeals the
highest court in the European Union
supported the agency directors demand
saying that Google was responsible for
the processing of personal data and that
people had a right to erasure or a right
to be forgotten so what's your
instinctive reaction to this maybe you
feel a strong sympathy for decent people
who are just trying to get out from
under the shadow of the worldwide web
who want their pasts to be private on
the other hand do we want business
people handling our money for example to
be able to erase a prior bankruptcy or a
politician to delete some troubling
behavior from the past the problem with
the EU court's ruling is that the
boundaries for lodging a complaint are
so incredibly vague and open to
interpretation the court only says that
information which is no longer relevant
or timely can be erased but who gets to
decide that American legal scholars are
confident that such a law would not be
passed in the states where free speech
protected by the First Amendment is
champion more readily than each
individual's right to privacy though
both are precious to us a recent Pew
study found that 68 percent of American
Internet users believe current laws are
not good enough in protecting people's
privacy online and 86 percent have taken
steps to mask their digital footprint
privacy is not a word that appears in
the US Constitution the right to privacy
is a relatively recent concept
introduced by Louis Brandeis in an essay
in the Harvard Law Review from 1890 this
question is really hard to work out what
effects do my demands to have this
picture of me doing a keg stand taking
off some random blog have on an open and
free internet it's not readily apparent
but when Google or Facebook are burdened
with that choice at the peril of fines
or worse then the path of least
resistance may be to say just take it
down and I think we could all see the
slippery slope in that in the
description under works cited I'll leave
links to educated opinions on both sides
of this art
the US and Europe are primed it seems to
go down different roads here and I can't
say which is the right one it's easy to
choose between liberty and constraint
but to make a judgment call is much
harder when two liberties are at odds
with each other
there's so many things to read about
this if nothing else
check out Louie Brandeis is essay on the
right to privacy it is just a seminal
essay in the history of law comment
below or ask me anything on tumblr I'll
put the link in the description thanks
for watching I'll see you next Friday